que pensez-vous du duo Macron borne
et ben voilà une bonne question ce duo
pour le mois inattendu le super
jupitérien et sa super intendance c'est
comme ça que vous les voyez
incontestablement depuis précisément on
a vu Nicolas Sarkozy et François Fillon
qui est tous les deux au départ avec
théorisé le Premier ministre
collaborateur
incontestablement quelqu'un comme
Elisabeth borne comme Jean Castex
d'ailleurs se situe plutôt dans cette
héritage là qui est lié à la
surpriseidentialisation du système ou le
Premier ministre n'est pas véritablement
le celui ou celle qui dirige le
gouvernement et l'exécutant de la
volonté président en l'espèce
manifestement elle n'était pas son
premier choix elle n'était pas son
premier choix alors
nonobstance et qualités qui sont réelles
et la manière dont je trouve elle s'est
imposée alors que il y avait quand même
beaucoup de critiques beaucoup de
réticences au départ elle s'est imposée
comme quelqu'un qui est capable aussi de
jouer de jouer son rôle de d'entraîner
un gouvernement de jouer un rôle de
négociation sociale ce qu'elle sait très
bien faire ou même politique en revanche
c'est très clair que dans ma chronique
dans le système macronien il y a un
président qui est jupiterien et qui
décide de tout et on voit bien y compris
sur la réforme des retraites très
récemment dans son discours aux Français
du 31 décembre c'est lui qui a donné le
cadre de ce qui était la réforme si vous
comparez avec ce qui s'était passé en
1995 pour une réforme similaire en tout
cas quelque chose qui a les braquer
beaucoup de Français c'est Alain Juppé
qui a un carnet totalement la réforme à
lui alors justement il y a la lettre il
y a l'esprit de la Constitution ces
rédacteurs avaient très clairement
Michel Debré en tête créer un partage un
périmètre avec des rôles très clairs le
président au dessus de la mêlée garant
de l'unité de la nation le Premier
ministre qui gouverne qui gouverne et
est-ce que ce partage là a été respecté
une fois dans l'histoire ou très vite le
président a grignoter du pouvoir très
vite le président du pouvoir le général
de Gaulle le premier en réalité c'est
vrai que de Gaulle avait son domaine
réservé là les affaires étrangères la
défense il gouvernait avec des ministres
qui lui mettaient fidèles permet ce
merdes à côté nord-est de Murville et
laissait a priori les affaires
intérieures à Adobe mais en réalité dès
que ça devenait chaud dès que ça
devenait important c'est le président
qui qui prenait la main prenons quelques
exemples on va les regarder sur cet
écran de Gaulle Pompidou c'est plutôt
l'entente parfaite du moins au début du
mois au début parce que Pompidou avait
été son directeur de cabinet donc au
fond pour de Gaulle c'était assez
naturel que en tant que Premier ministre
il soit une de super directeurs de
cabinet mais il l'a laissé faire il
allait vraiment laissé faire et tout le
projet de relance économique le projet
industriel de Pompidou c'était vraiment
Georges Pompidou jusque jusqu'au moment
de crise jusqu'au moment de rupture qui
a été la crise de Mai 68 parce que là en
mai 68 de Gaulle a été complètement
dépassé par les événements Pompidou a
pris des choses en main l'entourage de
Georges Pompidou certains voulaient même
que voilà que on fasse partir le général
de Gaulle et là ça c'est ça s'est cassé
parce que dès que le premier mise prend
un petit peu trop d'importance mort un
peu sur le périmètre du président de la
République ça peut plus fonctionner
Mitterrand Maurois c'est intéressant
parce que là c'est l'histoire d'un
couple parfait au départ chacun est dans
son rôle chacun se respecte mon roi
admir Mitterrand tout le monde le sait
et puis tout va dérailler oui alors et
Mitterrand avait une grande affection
pour pour Pierre Mauroy mais tout a
déraillé finalement assez vite
ça c'est moins sûr parce que dès
198283 il y avait le projet
éventuellement de remplacer mon roi par
Jacques Delors ou par d'autres bon mais
sa véritablement explosé en 1994 sur la
question de l'école enfin du service
unique de l'enseignement public qui
était prévu par par les socialistes que
Mauroy a soutenu ou plutôt il a soutenu
son ministre de l'éducation nationale
qui était Alain Savary que détestait
Mitterrand et mitterrances à sacrifié et
à utiliser Mauroy comme fusible comme ça
s'est fait beaucoup sous la Cinquième
République l'hyper présidentialisation
ça c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui l'a inventé
qu'il a porté à son paroxysme oui ça
c'est une certitude l'hyper Président
c'est la manière d'intervenir
directement depuis l'Élysée sur tous les
problèmes qui se posaient de réagir
comme ça à tout bout de champ ce qui
fait que des facto vous vous empiétez
sur le domaine du Premier ministre ce
qu'il avait plus ou moins autorisé en
l'appelant son collaborateur ce que
Fillon lui-même avant d'arriver à
Matignon avait lui-même reconnu et puis
c'était intéressant c'est que à
l'épreuve des faits François Fillon a
voulu reconquérir son territoire et ça a
donné des des scènes de ménage
perpétuels entre les deux hommes que je
raconte dans le livre parce que
c'est pas si simple que ça de rester un
premier ministre aux ordres du président
et puis elle est rivaux alors là on
aurait pu prendre plein de couples on
pourrait prendre du terreau regard on a
choisi Hollande Valls pour rester proche
de nous rivaux ou pas rivaux c'est
compliqué parce que au début ils sont
très quand même très main dans la main
pour essayer de redresser ce qui s'est
passé pendant les deux années où
Jean-Marc Ayraud était un métillon où ça
c'est pas très bien ça a pas très bien
fonctionné c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et va le servir comme un super
communicant quelqu'un qui a une très
bonne popularité et qui va aider
François Hollande à retrouver justement
cette popularité perdue et puis et puis
il y a un troisième larron et c'est ça
surtout qui va mettre de le feu dans ce
dans ce couple qui fonctionnait
finalement pas si mal au départ
troisième lance c'est c'est Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron qui prend de plus
en plus de d'importance en tant que
ministre et je me souviens qu'avec
Emmanuel Valls quand même la principale
question des journalistes c'était est-ce
que vous êtes est-ce que vous serez
loyal alors c'est déjà qu'il y a un loup
non oui parce que il y a toujours un
loup quand vous avez un Premier ministre
qui a la perspective la possibilité à un
moment ou un autre de devenir président
de la République il y a forcément un
moment quelque chose qui va se tendre
entre entre les deux hommes alors
quelquefois ça s'est tendu après c'était
le cas pour pour Pompidou et de Gaulle
ils ont quand même tenu presque jusqu'au
bout mais mais en général quand vous
avez un Premier ministre qui a une
ambition regardez ce qui s'est passé
avec Édouard Philippe tout montre que la
théorie du fusible du parano
paratonnerre est complètement
terminé et on en est on en est vraiment
sorti puisque le président décide de
tout tout procède de l'eau d'huile
est-ce que ça peut durer longtemps comme
ça à l'heure de la réforme des
institutions est-ce que il faut pas
mettre fin à l'hypocrisie on supprime le
Premier ministre et en rendant
responsable président devant moi
exactement pour l'inverse en fait moi je
pense qu'au contraire il faut revenir à
l'esprit initial de la 5e République
pourquoi parce que si vous enlevez au
président de la République le pouvoir
d'être un super Premier ministre et un
chef de majorité parlementaire qu'il est
parce que objectivement les élections
législatives arrivent juste après la
présidentielle et font du président un
chef de majorité parlementaire qui n'est
plus le président de tous les Français
il est le chef de 35% des Français donc
si vous redonnez au Premier ministre
cette fonction qui est la sienne de
diriger le gouvernement et de diriger la
majorité vous permettez au président de
s'abstraire de s'exclure de ce j'allais
dire du marigot politique
avant les présidentielles comme c'était
le cas mais en tout cas déconnecter les
deux élections et refaire je le répète
du Premier ministre un véritable chef de
gouvernement ça s'appelle Elisée contre
Matignon de 1958 à nos jours chez
Taillandier le couple infernal on plonge
dans la 5e République avec plaisir